here's a shocking update from the daily
wire Carly Russell the 25 year old
nursing student who claimed that she was
kidnapped earlier this month while
allegedly checking on a toddler on the
side of the road in Alabama
admitted to law enforcement that she
fabricated her entire story
I can't believe it
whoever saw this coming aside from
everyone who besides everyone saw this
coming
Russell attorney Emery Anthony had
originally made an appointment for
investigators to speak with Russell but
shortly before the interview set to
begin Anthony provided a statement to
law enforcement and asked that
authorities read the entire statement at
their press conference
the statement said there was no
kidnapping on Thursday July 13th my
client did not see a baby on the side of
the road
my client apologizes for her actions
this community the volunteers who were
searching for her to the Hoover Police
Department and other agencies as well as
to her friends and family we asked for
your prayers for Carly as she addresses
her issues and attempts to move forward
understanding that she made a mistake in
this matter Carly again asks for your
forgiveness and prayers
Hoover Police Chief Nick durzis said
that investigators are still going to
meet with Anthony Anthony because they
have more to discuss in the case
including the possibility that criminal
charges will be filed
which of course they absolutely should
be I mean it would be a disgrace if they
weren't if they weren't
um
you know they were filed against Jesse
Smollett as well they should be uh this
is worse in a lot of ways just in in the
amount of law enforcement resources that
were taken up because of this
so uh
it was fake the the story that was the
most obvious fake story of all time
turns out to be fake the thing we all
knew was fake is fake that's the big
headline uh Russell you know
Carly Russell she made some missteps
here there were some mistakes
um some classic fake your own kidnapping
mistakes the first mistake is to do it
in the first place
so that's mistake number one the first
mistake that you make when you uh fake
your own kidnapping is that you're
faking your own kidnapping
but if you're going to do it and I'm not
encouraging anyone to do it certainly
and I I don't mean to give advice on how
to do it properly but like some basic
I've never done it myself I've never
even considered faking my own kidnapping
but but even I would know like don't
Google don't Google kidnapping movies
the day before you get you you're faking
your kidnap
um don't stop for snacks on your way to
being kidnapped
that's that's generally not how it works
because for one thing you know if you're
being kidnapped you wouldn't know it
usually and even if you did know it
somehow the kidnappers are not like you
bring snacks
and I you know I've never been kidnapped
so I don't know but I'm pretty sure they
won't generally like if you're getting
kidnapped they won't and you say wait a
minute I got some trail I got some trail
mix uh in my car can I go grab it oh
yeah sure grab it we don't want you to
get hungry
so um don't stop for snacks like she did
um here's a big one don't stage the
kidnapping on the side of a major
highway
you know the list goes on but that last
part is it's a very common Mistake by
hoaxers think about Jesse Smollett he
staged his whole thing you know on a on
a street corner in the city with his
security cameras all over the place uh
think about Althea Bernstein the girl
who claimed that she was set on fire by
a group of of white supremacists in
Hawaiian shirts while she was waiting at
a stoplight some Hawaiian shirt white
supremacist repelled down from a
helicopter or something and uh and set
her on fire in the car
um but she claimed this I have an at us
at an intersection in a city
and then you've got um Carly Russell so
they're always faking these things in
really well populated areas where there
are witnesses who would be able to see
it happen if it did happen and there are
cameras and all the rest of it so if
you're gonna do it go out into the
country somewhere like go out into the
woods
um claim that you were on a camping trip
or something
um claim that it happened out on the
Appalachian Trail because at least then
there's always plausible deniability
nobody will be able to prove that you're
lying
so if you say that you were on the
Appalachian Trail and you were taken you
were you were uh you were kidnapped by a
gang of whoever
and taken to a Shack in the woods
somewhere
I think a lot of people doubt the story
but that should prove it didn't happen
you can't happen in the woods what do
you know
the thing is if you if you stage it on
the side of a highway or on a busy
street corner people can actually prove
that it didn't happen they can prove the
negative
so
um those are awesome things keep mine
but the best thing you could really do
is not go this route at all in your life
um just find whatever you're looking for
attention sympathy uh there
are other ways to achieve that goal
which even that goal you shouldn't be
pursuing as many of you know I was not
super thrilled when my family got a dog
but they're obsessed with it which is
why despite my own distaste for The
Mangy Beast I love making my family
happy and part of doing that is keeping
this freeloader as healthy as possible
which is why I give my dog rough greens
Dr Dennis black the founder of rough
greens is focused on improving the
health of every dog in America little
did I know before I got rough grains dog
food is dead food everybody knows that
nutrition is not brown it's green well
let rough grains boost your dog's food
back to life rough greens is a
supplement that contains all the
necessary vitamins minerals probiotics
Omega oils digestive enzymes and
antioxidants that your dog needs you
don't have to go out and buy new dog
food you just sprinkle rough Greens on
their food every day dog owners
everywhere are raving about rough grains
that support supports healthy joints
improves bad breath boosts energy levels
and so much more we are what we eat and
that goes for dogs too Dr Dennis black
is so confident rough greens will
improve your dog's health he's offering
my listeners a free jump start trial bag
so your dog could try it a free
jumpstart trial bag can be at your door
in just a few business days go to
roughgreens.com Walsh or call 844 rough
700 that's free Ruff greens.com Walsh or
call 844 rough 700 today picture if you
will the perfect Summer Night the warm
breeze on your face as you Lounge in
your favorite chair outside the grill is
sizzling with the Juicy Burgers the
aroma the food is irresistible in your
mouth Waters as you wait for it to be
cooked to Perfection now imagine what
this perfect summer night would look
like if you went to turn on the grill
and your propane tank was empty dear God
that's where my friends at cinch come in
and save the day cinch is a propane
grill tank Home Delivery Service they
deliver propane tanks right to your door
cinch delivers on your schedule and does
not require any long-term commitment or
subscription plus delivery is completely
contactless so you don't have to wait
around at home just track the order on
the Cinch app from anywhere whether
you're a grilling for the sweet baby
game camping with your family or
lighting up your fire pit on a cold
summer night cinches propane delivery
service ensures that you have the fuel
that you need to make the most of every
moment go online to cinch.com or
download their app to order new
customers can get their first tank
exchange for this ten dollars with promo
code walls that's Cyn ch.com promo code
Walsh this is a limited time offer and
you must live within a cinch service
area to redeem it visit cinch.com offer
for details so what happens next well we
know what's going to happen next in fact
Carly's boyfriend has already sort of
set the stage I want you to listen to
this report from uh Good Morning America
listen
and now the new questions about Carly
Russell's disappearance her boyfriend is
talking about what happened and asking
people to stop bullying her Eva Pilgrim
joins us now with the latest good
morning Eva good morning Lindsay there
are a lot of questions this morning and
police say they think only one person
can provide those answers Carly Russell
herself they are urging her to speak
with them the theories as to what
happened growing now one of those
closest to her coming out on her behalf
this morning as questions swirl around
Carly Russell's disappearance her
boyfriend speaking out defending her
Russell claimed she was kidnapped but
escaped to return home 49 hours later to
Mar Latrell Simmons telling the New York
Post I want everyone to stop bullying
her I know what it seems like what she
did just stop bullying on social media
adding think about her mental health
nobody deserves to be Cyber Bullied
oh on the contrary sir uh some people do
deserve to be Cyber Bullied and your
girlfriend is one of them or your
ex-girlfriend I guess now I will say
that that was a statement yesterday I
believe but this morning it came out
with another statement where he
denounces her and basically says you
know he's horrified by it and he had no
idea
um I don't believe like I don't believe
that her family and her friends didn't
know that she was faking it
you know her boyfriend came out
defending her her parents did the inner
a tearful interview talking about how
traumatized she was and I just don't buy
no way for me to know I don't know
what's going on inside their heads
I personally don't buy at all that they
didn't know
that she was faking it which isn't to
say that they were in on it or helped
her stage The hoax but I certainly think
that they knew even when they went out
claiming that it was real now
admittedly if you have a close family
member or friend who does something like
this they've put you in a really
difficult spot because you might not
want to go out to the media and denounce
your own family member or your child I
can understand that
but then what you do see if this was me
and I had a child who did something like
this
um I'm probably not going to immediately
go out to the media and say uh this
person's a liar don't listen to him no
I'm going to go to my child and say you
need to go and tell the truth
you know or I will
um but you need to do it
but what you don't do is go on do do
media interviews
uh repeating the lie that you must know
or at least strongly suspect is a lie
so uh but the bit you heard there about
mental health you know that's where this
is going to uh that's that's where
they're going to take this right is that
you already heard kind of a
there was an allusion to that in the
statement from the lawyer she doesn't
work through her issues and the
boyfriend talks about mental health and
so that's what they're going to say this
is a mental health like very similar to
the the excuse for State Stacy Lawton
Barry Lawton calling in the bomb threat
we heard from Dr Drew oh it's a mental
health episode
uh no like we're not we're not doing
that this is where they always take it
blaming poor Mental Health
it's a mental health episode or whatever
whatever else
um but mental health is not an excuse
for bad character for bad choices for
being a liar and a cheat and a hoaxer
and and being manipulative it's not an
excuse
mental health becomes this catch-all
excuse for everything and no matter what
anyone does they can always fall back on
oh yeah if I was suffering from bad
mental health so it's never something
that you did it's something that you're
suffering from it's something that's
happening to you
so on uh externally it seems like very
much you are making deliberate choices
Carly Russell planned this out she
planned its dumbly she planned it
stupidly
uh is very bad planning but she did plan
it is an extremely deliberate Act
with um with forethought
put into it
so
this was not a some sort of full-on
psychotic break where someone loses
their grip on reality and thinks that
the the you know thinks that their uh
space alien or the Queen of England or
something
um
no it's a deliberate choice and and more
and more what you find is that we are
taking choice
out of the equation we're taking
character out of the equation
because every bad choice is is uh is a
prod is because of bad mental health
um all bad character traits character
flaws well that's just a product of bad
mental health
put them on drugs and they'll be fine
that's gonna be the excuse here uh
guaranteed hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there